le monde avait les yeux rivés dessus
vous le savez depuis des mois ces 25
millions de tonnes de céréales bloqué en
territoire ukrainien par cette invasion
russe qui a débuté le 24 février dernier
après des semaines d'âpres négociations
moscou et kiev sont donc parvenus à un
accord sous l'égide de la turquie et des
nations unies la signature je vous le
disais doit avoir lieu d'un instant à
l'autre à istanbul sous le regard de
redjep tayyip erdogan et d'antonio
goûter res l'accord doit permettre donc
une sortie par la mer noire de ces
céréales mais aussi un allègement des
entraves à l'exportation de grains et
engrais russe on retrouve donc shauna
bhattacharya sur place bonjour shauna il
faut le dire dans ce dossier des
réticences ukrainiennes ont été très
nombreuses
le ministre de l'infrastructure du
gagnant oleg bratok qui refusent la
présence
dans cette eau du rial et exige d'avoir
une forte présence des forces armées
effet miel en mer noire à la délégation
s'est également il fut brève important
de signer un accord irek avec là-haut
seulement de finir avec la turquie et
les nations unies pour sa part de son
côté
le même accord mais on peut actuellement
avec laquelle les nations will en phase
de signature du même document par les
deux délégations
c'est très très important et puis au
final la dégaine une refus de toute
cette forte russie navire transportant
entre enyele qui n'y sont nombreux ces
exigences sont respectées
il faut de la
annonce que trop fort dans la région de
l'état serait débloquée lomba en premier
temps et puis peut-être aussi l'accord
est respecté tôt déjà il faudrait donc
là la signature de cet accord
mais on fait la même
merci mon kouchner on trouve bien sûr un
peu plus tard